ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER
RELEASED THE FINDINGS OF HIS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ACTIONS
OF POLICE MANY FERGUSON,
MISSOURI.
I'M CURIOUS.
WHATEVER DID HE FIND?
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RELEASED A 105-PAGE REPORT THAT
OFFICIALLY CONFIRMED WHAT
PROTESTERS IN FERGUSON,
MISSOURI, HAVE BEEN CLAIMING FOR
MONTHS, THAT LONG BEFORE BROWN'S
KILLING, FERGUSON POLICE
TARGETED AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> Larry: NO (BLEEP)!
SERIOUSLY, GUYS.
THE REPORT CONCLUDES THE
FERGUSON COPS ARE RACIST?
I CAME TO THAT CONCLUSION ON
CHAPTER FOUR OF THE REPORT I
PUBLISHED LAST AUGUST.
LARRY WILMORE'S INVESTIGATION OF
THE FERGUSON POLICE
DEPARTMENT -- LET'S SEE --
(APPLAUSE)
OH, HERE IT IS.
CHAPTER 4.
RIGHT HERE.
I HAD IT.
CHAPTER 4.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'M TELLING YOU.
THAT WAS EXHAUSTIVE RESEARCH.
OKAY.
AND IN OTHER GOOD NEWS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ALSO
ANNOUNCED THAT OFFICER DARREN
WILSON WILL NOT FACE FEDERAL
CHARGES FOR KILLING MICHAEL
BROWN.
WHICH IS GOOD BECAUSE IT FREES
WILSON UP TO TRAVEL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN A VAN SOLVING
MYSTERIES WITH GEORGE ZIMMERMAN.
(LAUGHTER)
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
BUT FORGET WILSON, ERIC HOLDER'S
GOT SOME TRULY INSANE STATS IN
THIS REPORT.
>> 67% OF FERGUSON'S POPULATION
IS BLACK, BUT BETWEEN 2012 AND
2014, THEY ACCOUNTED FOR 85% OF
PEOPLE PULLED OVER BY FERGUSON
POLICE AND 93% OF PEOPLE
ARRESTED.
WHEN POLICE USED FORCE, NEARLY
NINE TIMES OUT OF TEN, THEY USED
IT AGAINST BLACKS.
>> Larry: NINE OUT OF TEN,
THEY USED FORCE AGAINST BLACKS?
SO WHO'S THE ONE WHITE GUY?
WHAT DID HE DO?
TRY TO GET IN THE WAY OF THE
POLICE BEATING UP THE NINE BLACK
GUYS?
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
FIGURES.
STUPID ONE WHITE GUY.
BUT THE FERGUSON POLICE GO OUT
OF THEIR WAY TO ARREST US.
>> AFRICAN-AMERICANS MADE UP
OVER 90% OF THOSE CHARGED WITH A
HIGHLY DISCRETIONARY OFFENSE
DESCRIBED AS, AND I QUOTE,
"MANNER OF WALKING ALONG
ROADWAY."
>> Larry: MANNER OF WALKING
ALONG THE ROADWAY?
THEY'RE ARRESTING BLACK GUYS FOR
WALKING?
YOU KNOW, IT'S FUNNY, IT REMINDS
ME OF THAT OLD STANDUP JOKE --
WHITE PEOPLE WALK LIKE THIS.
"I'M WALKING!"
BLACK PEOPLE WALK LIKE THIS.
(SIRENS)
WHOA, WHOA!
HEY, HEY!
HEY, GUYS!
I'M DOING A BIT!
(APPLAUSE)
AND WORST OF ALL, THEY TURNED
MAN'S BEST FRIEND INTO THE BLACK
MAN'S WORST ENEMY.
>> AND USE OF DOGS BY FERGUSON
POLICE APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN
EXCLUSIVELY RESERVED FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IN EVERY CASE IN WHICH FERGUSON
POLICE RECORDS RECORDED THE RACE
OF A PERSON BIT BY A POLICE DOG,
THAT PERSON WAS
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
>> Larry: SICCING DOGS ON
BLACK PEOPLE?
THAT'S A LITTLE ON THE NOSE,
RACIST POLICE DEPARTMENT.
YOU HAVEN'T COME UP WITH
ANYTHING NEW IN 50 YEARS?
HARPER LEE IS DROPPING FRESH
MATERIAL FASTER THAN YOU.
BUSTING BLACKS HAS EVEN BECOME A
GAME TO THE WILEY FERGUSON
COPPERS.
>> SOME OFFICERS EVEN COMPETE TO
SEE WHO CAN ISSUE THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF CITATIONS DURING A
SINGLE STOP.
A TOTAL THAT AT LEAST IN ONE
INSTANCE ROSE AS HIGH AS 14.
>> Larry: 14 CITATIONS IN ONE
STOP?
HOW MANY THINGS CAN YOU DO WRONG
WHILE DRIVING WHILE BLACK?
LET'S SEE, CHANGING LANES WHILE
BLACK, ALMOST EXPIRED TAGS WHILE
BLACK, TALKING BACK WHILE BLACK,
HAVING OTHER BLACK PEOPLE IN THE
CAR WHILE BLACK, BEING BLACK
WHILE BLACK.
MAN, I CAN ONLY THINK OF SIX!
THESE COMES ARE GOOD!
-- THESE COPS ARE GOOD!
BUT TO BE FAIR, THE COPS AREN'T
ONLY CITING BLACKS OUT OF SPORT.
THEY'RE ALSO DOING IT AS A
MONEY-MAKING SCHEME.
>> TODAY THE CITY GENERATES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF REVENUE
FROM THE ENFORCEMENT OF CODE
PROVISIONS.
ALONG WITH TAXES AND OTHER
REVENUE STREAMS IN 2010, THE
CITY COLLECTED OVER $1.3 MILLION
IN FINES AND FEES COLLECTED BY
THE COURT.
FOR FISCAL YEAR 2015, FERGUSON'S
CITY BUDGET ANTICIPATES THE
REVENUES TO EXCEED $3 MILLION,
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE TOTAL FROM
JUST FIVE YEARS PRIOR.
>> Larry: YEE-HAW!
THAR'S GOLD IN THEM THERE
BLACKS!
WE STRUCK BLACK GOLD!
(GUNFIRE)
I THINK I GOT NINE OF THEM!
(SIREN)
WHOA!
GUYS, GUYS!
>> WE HAVE BEEN GETTING A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT A BLACK GUY
WAIVING SOME GUNS AROUND.
>> Larry: HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
I'M JUST DOING A BIT.
THEY'RE FINGER GUNS.
>> USING FINGER GUNS IS
PROHIBITED BY FERGUSON CITY
ORDINANCE --
>> Larry: WE'RE NOT IN
FERGUSON!
WE'RE IN NEW YORK.
I'M DOING A COMEDY SHOW.
>> REALLY?
A COMEDY SHOW?
WITH AN UPSIDE-DOWN MAP!
WHAT'S THE JOKE?
>> Larry: IT'S NOT A JOKE.
IT'S ABOUT HOW YOU SEE THE
WORLD.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
>> REALLY IN WHAT'S YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS $300
UPSIDE-DOWN MAP TICKET?
>> Larry: YOU CAN'T JUST WRITE
ME A CITATION!
>> LOOK AT THIS DESK.
THE HELL THEY IS THIS?
RECTANGLE?
TRIANGLE?
I HATE IT.
$450 UGLY DESK FINE.
>> Larry: YOU CAN'T JUST STOP
ME IN THE MIDDLE OF MY SHOW.
>> YES, I CAN.
I CAN STOP YOU IF YOU HAVE A
BROKEN TAILLIGHT.
>> Larry: MY DESK DOESN'T HAVE
TAILLIGHTS.
>> TELL THAT TO THE BROKEN
TAILLIGHT ON YOUR DESK.
>> Larry: WHEN DID I GET A
TAILLIGHT?
I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER HAVING A
TAILLIGHT!
>> LOOK, IT WAS THERE.
AND LET ME SEE YOUR
REGISTRATION.
>> Larry: I HAVE A SCRIPT.
I DON'T HAVE A REGISTRATION.
THIS IS COME DI!
>> THIS IS TIME SLOT WAS
REPORTED STOLEN A FEW MONTHS
AGO, BY AN S. COLBERT.
>> Larry: I DIDN'T STEAL IT
FROM S. COLBERT.
THIS IS MY TIME SLOT!
I'VE HAD IT SINCE JANUARY!
I DIDN'T STEAL ANYTHING!
>> CALM DOWN, SIR.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE GATHERED
UP THERE.
THIS LOOKS LIKE UNLAWFUL
ASSEMBLY!
>> Larry: IT'S AN AUDIENCE!
OKAY?
CAN I PLEASE JUST GET BACK TO MY
SHOW?
>> AH, OKAY.
I'LL BE WATCHING YOU.
>> Larry: GOOD!
WE'RE ON AT 11:30 EVERY NIGHT!